hi i'm angela hey guys it's ferrari hi
i'm [ __ ] hi i'm sushi i grew up in
mumbai and i've been living in new york
for about eight years i'm from boston my
family's from south india i'm from
bangladesh originally but i grew up in
boston i'm from chicago but my family is
from hyderabad india today i have for
you my version of chana masala i love
chana masala ate it pretty much my
entire life at every wedding i went to
took it to school as well i think what
makes a good chana masala is good
consistency on the paste before you cook
it so you take a lot of the vegetables
blend them up a curry that's not too
thin not too thick ginger normally goes
into chana masala a lot there wasn't any
at the stove so i had to make it without
ginger we're gonna season it as well
with a little bit of cilantro just to
give it the extra kick
oh look at that presentation is key this
dish has a little garnishing on top
which i like i feel like this is comfort
food right here i can smell the garlic
ginger even from here so it's kind of
strong
i like this one it has like an onion
taste to it i love the garlic i love
garlic and everything so i definitely
taste it in here
i'm so sorry a lot of garlic ginger
i feel like i barely taste like the
chickpea and i taste more of the garlic
and ginger i like that you can taste all
the flavors in here i'd rate this out of
ten probably an eight what would make it
a ten probably if it was a little bit
more spicier i would probably make this
like eight i just think it's lacking a
little bit of salt i can taste the love
in it but it's not for me so i'm gonna
give it a three take out three fourths
of the garlic ginger add some salt some
red chili powder and some garam masala i
think it'd be great a good chana masala
as long as you have some spices some
flavor in it and give it your own
personal touch this is a traditional
south asian dish it's made from a puree
of tomatoes chickpeas that's basically
the base i'm gonna squeeze some lemon on
it i just feel like it adds so much more
flavor i like spice so i'm gonna add
some jalapenos too but i love bengali
food indian food that's my favorite food
i just think it has so much seasoning
and flavor in it i added my special
touch to it so i think they're gonna
enjoy it it looks really good i love
jalapenos i like that they added
jalapenos to it i think they'll give a
good kick
yeah that hits the spot oh my god i
think that really reminds me of like
great chana masala i've had back home
this is really good the jalapeno is
crunchy so it adds more texture and it's
not spicy which is perfect because i
don't really like spicy food it's a bit
tangy which i like it's not bland at all
i would say that for sure this reminds
me of devon avenue which is like india
town in chicago it's got kind of a nice
like tingle like after the fact too but
it's not like any specific flavor is
like really hitting me too hard it's
kind of just like all together this is a
very comfortable one i'll give it like
eight and a half i think this one
balance the flavors really well i wish
there was a little bit more jalapenos a
9 out of 10. i would probably add just a
little bit more garlic but that's it
it's not the most flavorful so i'm going
to give it a 6. the jalapenos are not
kicking in this so maybe make it a bit
more spicier that'd be a lot better i
love cheddar masala i grew up eating
china masala i used to make it all the
time with my parents with my
grandparents it's just one of my
favorite dishes it's comfort food for me
i think it's the easiest dish to make
and i prepared it with a lot of detail i
added spices to it it's a little spicy
and i put lemon i think lemon really
balances out the spiciness but i think
what makes it authentic is just adding
my own flavor to it i think the lemon is
something unique it kind of brings it
out a little bit this does look a bit
soupy i personally don't love when the
curry is like too thin this dish is
looking
like dog food it kind of looks bland
there's no color in it looks a bit
watery but it smells really really good
so i have high hopes for this one
that does taste good the spice is really
hitting the back of the throat that's
the masala of it all i talked my but i
was wrong this is pretty good it has
spices don't judge a book by its cover
the garam masala is so strong but i kind
of like that garam masala is a huge
thing to have in china masala you can
really really taste it and so it hits
that even though it looks watery if you
just mix it a little bit the consistency
is really nice so i'll give it an eight
i feel like the curry is a little too
like i don't know how this would mix
with other things but i think the spice
level is on point i'll go with like a
seven and a half this one i'm gonna give
a 8.5 i think this dish would be a 10 if
they added more color to it i grew up
eating indian food my parents only
cooked at home exclusively so i've had a
lot of indian cuisine china masala i do
have pretty often especially like
ramadan it's like a very staple iftar
dish i really like having a lot of
flavors in it you can like see like the
tomato chunks you can see like the
onions the garlic for most chuna masala
everything is blended besides the
chickpeas but in this all the vegetables
are just chopped so you can really taste
each vegetable that makes it better in
my opinion i love the color in this so
far i see the chunks of vegetables i
think it's onions and tomatoes it's a
little chunky like the chickpeas look
great i'm a bit thrown off by like the
vegetables being so chunky i think it's
perfect balance of spice
it's not too spicy i think i like this
one the best out of all the other ones
give it another go
seems like it's missing something like
some type of flavor in it like some type
of spice for that weird texture mesh
alone like i feel like i'm gonna have to
take away a few points i would go with a
seven i think it deserves points for the
flavor and for the heat i do like the
heat machado masala chunky vegetables
why you gotta get in the way like that
goddamn i really like that the
vegetables are kind of chunkier i think
you get a good taste of the veggies and
the chunda i think it's a good balance i
like it i would probably give this a 10
out of 10. i do taste that spice that
little kick and i like that but
maybe it needs more salt so for this one
i'm probably gonna rate it a seven but i
do like the chunkiness in it kind of
looks like a salsa i'm kind of surprised
i thought all the other dishes were
great it's eleven i think it did it i
think cheddar sauce is a great way to
like learn how to make indian food i
think it's like one of the easiest
things to make so have fun with it
[Music]
you